Follow lane focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's video is a quick video to
explain a concept that I often talk
about in my videos,
but the viewer sometimes don't
understand and they ask me about in the
comments.
The concept is grammatical case case
refers to the grammatical function of a
noun or a pronoun in the sentence.
For example,
if these are all the words in a
sentence,
eight lion honeybadger.
Ah,
there are two possible messages.
This one,
the lion ate the honeybadger or this
one,
the honey badger eight the lion.
There are two roles in the sentence.
The animal doing the eating and the
animal being eaten in English.
We normally know which role announced as
fulfilling based on word order.
The subject of the sentence comes here
and the object of a sentence comes here.
Prepositions can also tell us announce
function.
For example,
the honey badger gave a warning to the
snake.
The preposition to tells us the snake is
the indirect object receiving the
action.
But in many languages,
word order and prepositions are not the
main ways to show the function of it.
Now,
the form of the now might change or a
special ending might be added to the
word to show what's function in the
sentence.
In English,
we do this to show possession like in
the phrase the Lions defeat the
apostrophe s shows that the defeat
belongs to the lion and in English we
also have pronouns that changed for form
to show grammatical case.
For example,
I robbed her,
she robbed me,
I and she or the subject forms while me
and her are the object forms,
but there are languages that show
grammatical case much more than English
does.
The most common grammatical cases are
probably nominative,
accusative and genitive.
Nominative case generally indicates the
subject of a sentence which often means
the person or thing doing the action
like this and Arabic acolyte walla due
to fatten meaning the boy ate an apple.
Here.
We can see that the word for boy
[inaudible] has an e at the end because
it is the subject of the sentence and
nominative case can also indicate the
thing that the subject is equivalent to.
So in this sentence who are telling me
soon hear the word for student.
Tilimeers has wound at the end to
indicate nominative case because it is
equal to the subject.
This ending has the extra n sound at the
end because it's indefinite.
These kinds of changes to the form of a
word to show grammatical difference are
called inflections.
Accusative case generally indicates that
direct object of a verb in Arabic,
it has that use along with some other
uses.
For example,
[inaudible] which means I drink milk
here,
the word for milk Halib has an ah at the
end to indicate that it's the direct
object or the accusative case.
Genitive case generally indicates that
one noun is being modified by another
one often to show possession.
We dotty [inaudible] meaning the boys
teacher here.
The word for boy wallet has an e sound
at the end to show possession.
Those are probably the three cases
you're most likely to run into,
but depending on the language,
there are numerous other cases.
Well,
the date of case is generally used for a
noun which receives something.
Something moves towards that.
Now [inaudible] I didn't give the girl
money here.
The Latin word for girl who in La has an
e at the end to indicate that she is the
indirect object on the receiving end of
an action.
Locative case is used to indicate a
location.
Here's an example from Turkish Fda Beer
Kita aqua doom,
which means I read a book at home,
hear the word for HouseF has dead at the
end to show that it's the location where
the reading took place.
In English,
we use a separate preposition like at
[inaudible] or on to show location
rather than a case inflection.
Instrumental case is used for announced
that is used as a tool or a means of
completing an action.
Here's an example from Polish p shapew
with them,
which means I write with a pen,
the word for pen people.
It all ends with the final,
Oh,
which has replaced by e m because it's
the instrument being used to carry out
the action of writing.
Notice that because of that ending,
there was no need to add a standalone
preposition,
meaning with those are some of the most
common cases.
The main thing to keep in mind is that
the form of the now or of the Pronoun
changes depending on its function in the
sentence.
Sometimes cases apply not only to
announce,
but also to words that are connected to
them like adjectives and articles.
Here's an example of an adjective being
inflicted for case.
This time again in Arabic,
I'll have been to Al Jameela too,
which means the beautiful girl here,
the Noun for girl didn't has the
nominative case ending and so does the
adjective Jameela,
but the Arabic equivalent of h at the
end of the word changes to a t sound
before the case nd.
And here's an example of articles taking
case inflection.
This time from old English,
say Kooning,
the king.
In nominative case,
in the genitive case,
it's fast schooning gis salt.
The Noun is inflected with the genitive
ending.
And the definite article also has a
special form in the genitive case,
words have particular functions in all
languages of course,
but only in certain languages do they
commonly indicate these functions with
changes to the form of the work when
talking about languages that do.
So we often talk about now in cases or
case endings,
but remember that not only nouns can be
inflicted for case,
but also pronouns,
which represent nouns and also
adjectives which modify,
announce and articles which show whether
nouns or definite or indefinite.
I hope that was a helpful summary for
anyone who needed clarification.
So the quick question of the day,
do words in your language change form
depending on their function in the
sentence.
If you can think of an example,
let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
thanks to all of my patrion supporters,
especially these extra special ones
right here for their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Oh right.
And a happy new year.